sidi bou saïd vidée de ses habitants
mais surtout de ces milliers de
touristes annuels le village bleu et
blanc au lieu historique du tourisme
tunisien doit faire face comme le reste
du monde à cette crise sanitaire alors
comment la mairie mais surtout les
associations s'organisent face à socke
ovi 19
non monsieur le maire est ce que pouvez
vous expliquer comment la ville de sidi
bou saïd s'organisent face à ce qu vie
de 19 alors c'est très simple on s'est
organisé dès le début on a essayé de
préparer les villageois à rester chez
eux donc on a commencé petit à petit on
a décidé de fermer les restos et les
cafés et en plus on a rajouté une autre
chose c'est qu'on n'a publié sur la page
de la municipalité un communiqué pour
dire aux gens de rester chez eux il ya
des volontaires qui distribuent la
nourriture la nourriture les médicaments
on s'est organisé avec les pharmacies
avec le magasin général sidi bou saïd un
petit village donc l'organisation est
très très simple je pense par rapport
aux autres
honnêtement on n'est pas nombreux donc
le message passe rapidement pour le
maire du village historique protéger
l'ensemble de ses habitants est devenue
une priorité
un service de livraison à domicile salué
par l'ensemble des villageois la
municipalité fait son possible pour
venir en aide surtout aux personnes les
plus isolées en leur apportant de quoi
vivre et il faut noter qu'il ya beaucoup
de villageois qui contribuent à cette
initiative
les amis de l'association est en train
de faire leur boulot comme il faut et
merci beaucoup à eux
merci beaucoup à monsieur le maire merci
beaucoup à tout le monde de la
municipalité de sidi bou saïd qu'ils ont
donné tout ce qu'ils ont comme un
produit comme à alimentation comme un
sanitaire
comment un peu de sous pour ceux qui
n'ont pas au caméline comme tous les
jours et ce depuis le début
confinement les bénévoles de
l'association grosse bleus se haute à
livrer l'ensemble des habitants et que
l'on soit sur les hauteurs de la colline
de sidi bou saïd ou dans les zones les
plus reculées pour cette famille de
nécessite ul la visite des bénévoles de
la rose bleue est accueilli comme une
bénédiction
nous sommes très heureux de cette aide
est que l'association ne nous oublie pas
c'est une période difficile
bien sûr qui est ce qui va penser à nous
si ce n'est pas eux
alors d'où est venue cette idée de
distribution à sidi bou saïd comment
fonctionne l'association mais surtout
quel est le but de ces bénévoles
l'association la rose bleue en
collaboration avec la mairie petit du
succès et le mj magasin général la
pharmacie il est ici c'est le centre des
opérations de sidi bou said
on a deux types on a les nécessiteux on
livre est aussi on a les commandes de
jeu de ceux qui sont chez eux ne sortent
pas les vieux doivent rester chez eux
on nous passe là que les commandes
l'écran de la contamination
la courbe de la contamination à sidi bou
said jusqu'à présent elle est bien on
est à 0 respecter les règles du
confinement sans oublier la population
du village
voilà l'objectif que s'est fixé la ville
de sidi bou saïd en partenariat avec les
associations les autorités locales mais
aussi les habitants du village
objectif limiter un maximum la
propagation du virus